hey youtubers it's Charlie and there's
been so much news about the new flash TV
show that I wanted to do a big update on
which actors have been cast which
characters they're playing what the
storylines are going to be as well as
how it's going to integrate with arrow
also heads up I'm still collecting
questions for my arrow Q&A so feel free
to include any questions for the flash
or any related stuff in the comments if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure and subscribe to get it
so let's get started with the cast most
everyone's associated with the new 52
versions of their characters obviously
number one being Grant Gustin is Barry
Allen unless the arrow writers bring him
back for a cameo in the final episodes
of season 2 he's still in a coma
presumably he would wake up during the
flash pilot and his story would begin by
discovering house powered work and his
quest to solve the mystery of his
mother's death those two things will be
the biggest story arcs for season 1 on
to the main villain they are not holding
anything back they cast Rick cos net as
Eddie thaw aka professor zoom
he's like the Flash's Joker his greatest
enemy I'm so pumped he's on the show so
soon
the professor zoom character is a huge
part of the Flash's new 52 origin story
I don't spoil what that role is but you
can read all about it in the newest
version of the flash comics on the show
Barry and Eddie will both work in the
Central City Police Department the
character description that the WB
release forum makes it sound like he's
not going to reveal himself as Professor
zoom right away then there's detective
West and iris West
- huge characters from the comic books
Jesse Martin is playing detective West
he'll be like Barry's mentor iris is
being played by Candice Patton and she's
gonna be Barry's best friend on the show
it's unclear how much of their
backstories from the comic books will be
in the show they might change a few
things just because there's a big time
travel and predestination paradox aspect
to irises character be sure to read the
comic book if you want to learn more
about it but let's just say that every
major event in their lives as well as
their existence all loops back on itself
in this giant mobius strip of cause and
effect with Professor zoom at the center
now is actually a good time to mention
that the show is going to be much more
hard science fiction than arrow is think
of it as like a superhero CSI cross with
arrow the next villain the cast in the
show is danielle Panabaker as killer
frost in the comic books her real name
is Caitlin snow
she's a STAR Labs bio engineer whose
husband died in that particle
accelerator explosion
don't know if they'll show her getting
her powers during season one or if she's
going to already have him whenever it
picks up then there's Carlos Valdez he's
playing Cisco Ramon aka the vibe
character that a lot of you guys have
been asking me about he's like the Barry
Allen of STAR Labs really young really
smart just like the killer frost
character they haven't said whether or
not he's going to get his powers during
season one or if he's already gonna have
him when it starts
they might alter the character just a
little bit and make his powers come from
that explosion that gave Barry his
powers too in the comic books he
actually got them after being exposed to
a boom tube which is the
interdimensional gateway open when you
use a mother box that invokes Darkseid
and all this other crazy DC cannon that
might be a little too complicated for
the show so those aren't the only
characters but they are the main
characters they've actually already
started shooting the pilot grant gustin
even tweeted a picture of the script
right now the series is planned for a
fall 2014 debut but nothing has been
confirmed if they don't ear the pilot
this spring after the arrow season
finale and they'll probably do a
screening at Comic Con ideally the show
will just air back-to-back with arrow
whenever season three starts we'll
probably know whether or not that's
actually going to happen before the end
of arrow season two now let's talk about
some arrow crossover a lot of you been
asking about characters from arrow
appearing on flash and characters from
flash appearing on arrow
so first Felicity and Barry will still
be a thing those of you that know about
the iris West character she's actually
gonna be friends own did for most of
season one just like Oliver has friends
own Felicity but belissa Dee will
actually be the connective tissue
between the shows they'll probably be a
minor Felicity cameo on the flash maybe
Oliver too for the most part both shows
will have separate storylines but expect
Felicity to drop references every once
in a while the creative force behind
both of the shows is largely the same
but they will have different production
teams and different writers virtually
all of the arrow characters and villains
will also stay on arrow exclusively the
flash show will introduce its own
villains including you know Big Bad
professor zoom and killer frost remember
that arrow did not go crazy with super
villains in season 1 so kind of expect
the same thing from the flash in its
first season just with way more science
fiction so I hope that answered a lot of
your biggest questions about the flash
I'll be doing video updates as we get
new information so be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'm getting really
excited about the series they are not
holding anything back it's going to go
hardcore comic
and right away right now click here for
my latest arrow video and click here for
my Q&A video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you